hey yes this is andrew for sentences.com
so in my videos i like to show you guys
how
i set up my trades so i'm here to make
some technical analysis with you today
i'm going to talk about gamestop
and i'm going to try to show you all the
different signals that i'm seeing
on the charts and how i use the signals
to build my scenarios and to select my
preferred one
so let's get into it
[Music]
and guys so i'm following gamestop you
know since i basically started my
channel so this stock
is moving with very strong moves when
it's going
up actually and then it's consolidating
and you know
we had this whole period of time where
basically nothing much was happening
and now we are having to meet a
different situation guys
we're having here this breakout once
again this is the
you know huge breakout that happened
here the most important one guys the one
that is telling me that we are starting
the third wave you know
uh that is going to eight hundred in
this breakout we had
here the first wave one two three four
five then correction all right so this
is basically the situation that i'm
giving you guys
for quite some time you know since
basically this breakout happened on the
25th of may
uh you can go and check the videos i was
making at that time
so roughly one month ago and i told you
that we're gonna go higher roughly to
the 300 area
and then come back to the 220 guys and
this is what happened
now let's zoom in little bit and let me
show you guys what i'm seeing
here so the first thing i want to show
you guys is that here we having this
unidentified pattern here so basically
abc and
you know usually after an abc you have a
one two three four five but here we
having this
you know kind of wedge pattern flat
i'm not sure you know doing this kind of
double top double bottom pattern
and it's funny to see this after you
know this sharp abc
but look guys what actually
you can compare it to you can go on amc
chart because
guys amc did this move but
before and then we had this amazing
strong move up
and here guys when we broke out here you
know this is the same breakout
you know i disconnected the highs that
happen in the same time
here it was 25 and 15 and then i can
draw this
trend line we have the breakout here
then we correct it and look guys
look you know if i go under only time
frames i'm
basically going to use the same time
frame and i come back to this
breakout that happened here this is the
breakout that gamestop just did and this
is the connection to the 220 area
and look what kind of pattern i had just
here abc
and then the same an identified kind of
double
top here and then we have the strong
move up and look
gamestop is doing the same thing so why
not having the same
outcome and here having this strong move
up of the third of the third that would
start maybe on monday
and this would go together with my
analysis on amc
where i'm seeing actually the end of the
corrective pattern
that we're having here as well so this
is amc and i told you guys that i have
different scenarios but that my
preferred scenario is that we stay above
this 50 period moving average on that
time frame and that we do the strong
move up so maybe this would go together
it makes sense for me
now let me analyze the facts like i like
to do first and then i'm gonna
interpret those facts and tell you my
different scenarios
so for now the first fact guys is that
we're having this double top double
bottom pattern
just like we did for amc we are around
the
220 area that was the area where i
wanted gamestop to trade roughly
at this time before the strong move up
so this is all good for me
in terms of fibs guys you you know fibs
are very good to use to know like
how deep was the correction we are all
need to do 61.8
213. let me do it perfectly all right
the 214 area i guess
is basically exactly what we closed is
the 61.8
retracement so once again the 15 the
61.8 at the very typical retracement
level
where we see the second waves going to
be full bouncing back
so this is all good you know this is
just looking perfectly fine for me
in terms of levels if we go below this
i'm gonna start
to worry but i have kind of lower
level below which i need to rebuild kind
of my analysis that is 180 i'm gonna
come back to this
but for now we are at the 61.8
retracement level
of the first wave which is totally fine
for me
and let me show you guys something more
interesting that we're having here
on the hourly time frame guys once again
you know that i
really like to use divergences and here
look what we're having
i showed you we have a bearish
exaggerated divergence on amc
but we have the opposite divergence on
gm gamestop actually here
the market is not making lower lows even
making like higher lows
basically lower highs let's say it's
making lower highs and roughly the same
lows
and in the same time the macd is going
higher so
this is a bullish exaggerated divergence
it's this one basically the macd going
higher
and the price action making a double
bottom
so this is what we're having this is
bullish and here see that we're having
this kind of wedge pattern that we
usually have
before breakouts so basically this is
telling me
that this move down is weaker now
and that bears you know they can't make
new lows you know they just
can't do it the buying power is too
strong
for the bears to make new lows and you
can
see this because the magnet is going
higher so this is showing that
the trend is starting to reverse so i'm
expecting here a breakout coming
soon now what do we want to see guys
this is what we want to see
here you can see i connect the highs
that i have here and
you know a typical scenario so let's
call it my preferred scenario guys let's
call it my preferred scenario would be
we go here higher
we re-test it and bam and then we go
here and we do this
one two three four five so we go here
and then the second wave doesn't need to
go that low all right this is just
approximative but most likely it will go
higher so here you want to see this
breakout around the 225 7 area
we go higher we re-test it on the very
short term guys very short term so here
you need to be quick if you want to
enter this trade
but this is a very good signal that i
would use to enter my trade
you know i wait for the market once
again to trade here
above and then i buy the retest so i
would be a buyer
here guys in this area i wait for a
breakout
once again break out you need two
consecutive candles on the time frame
you're watching
and you need the confirmation in time
and spot all right so the breakout needs
to be
high enough we don't want to trade this
kind of fake breakouts and you need to
have
some strong associated volumes so it's
confirming that your breakout is correct
so let's have a look at the financial
data quickly
okay so gamestop is now trading at 215
so we have around seven percent of
synthetic short interest so once again
here i compute
all the option open interest i compute
the delta myself using black shells
formula guys
this formula here and then i compute the
exposure that i have
for every maturity and every strike and
i
sum it up guys and i have almost 1
billion usd in synthetic
short exposure then i add this data to
the regular showed interest that is
roughly around
12 million on the 28th of may i'm
waiting for the 15th of
june data to be released it's not here
yet so we're having roughly 27
of short interest which is a lot guys
which means there are a lot of people
to squeeze a lot of market makers or
hedge funds that are keeping the short
positions
on this market then i'm having as well
still guys you've probably seen this
many times but if you're new
on my channel you need to see this guys
this is
the craziest distribution of options
that i've ever seen in my life
i'm an option trader i mean i was i
resigned last week but whatever
and i've seen this kind of distribution
many times and i've never seen something
like this gamestop
is the one that has the most crazy
option
open interest distribution with the 800
strike covering almost by itself all the
other strikes
it's amazing guys and so the this one
billion
mostly comes from the 800 strike in
terms of exposure not yet but in terms
of number of shares it does
so this is very bullish and this is
going to create the gamma squeeze and
some very bullish momentum if we start
to go higher
but we will i think according to my
analysis
so guys this is for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys